用声音 碰撞世界。
生动活泼
嗨 我是早咖啡的兼职泽林。
我们节目组正在寻找新伙伴。
如果你对商业世界好奇。
也喜欢声音这个媒介。
欢迎去单机介绍里点招聘入口看看。
那我们接下来就进入今天的节目吧？
生动早咖啡
与你轻松同步 日常生活 与商业世界。
嗨 各位 早上好呀？
今天是2026年的6月17号 星期三。
这里是生动早咖啡。
我是来自生动活泼的梦音。
世界杯比赛给小红书带来了多少用户。
哪些机构参与了Deepsea第一次外部融资。
今天上半段就和你一起来了解这些问题。
那在今天节目的后半段。
想和你来关注一个可能没有留意过的咖啡玩家。
东鹏
其实说起这家公司。
你大概率会想到他们推出的能量预料。
或者是请到了足球球星姆巴佩。
担任代言人的电解治水。
不过快消品监测机构马上赢的数据显示。
今年5月 东鹏旗下的紧影咖啡产品。
在中国线下零售市场所占据的销售额份额。
已经上升到了第二名 略高于星巴克。
而第一名确潮在长期掌握着。
中国紧影咖啡市场接近一半的份额。
那所谓紧影咖啡就是瓶装或者是罐装的咖啡饮品。
开盖就能够喝
见面新闻指出 东鹏和星巴克这两家品牌。
在紧影咖啡市场的差距还不到1%。
行业的位置仍然可能会继续的波动。
那东鹏这家能量饮料企业的集团。
他们做咖啡 接下来还会面临着怎样的挑战呢？
我们先来留两几条新鲜的商业科技动态。
之后亲戚读时间就会和你来展开这个话题。
小红书筹备香港上市。
根据彭博社6月15号的报道。
小红书正在准备在这个月底之前。
香港交所递交上市申请。
具体的上市时间 规模还有估值都还在讨论当中。
小红书在2024年的融资当中估值大约171美元。
去年9月涨到了300多亿美元。
小红书之前还向股东表示。
2025年利润可能会达到大约30亿美元。
不过界面新闻此前的分析认为。
小红书的广告收入占到总营收的接近8成。
电商等等新业务规模和抖音快手等等平台相比。
仍然有差距
商业模式也没有完全摆脱对广告的依赖。
另外小红书最近也披露了。
世界杯开赛前三天的数据。
观看直播的用户当中。
男性用户的占比超过了6成。
开赛首日
小红书观看直播的人数。
也和开赛之前相比增长了55倍。
打破了平台直播在线人数的历史峰值。
DeepSig完成首轮融资。
根据Information 6月16号的报道。
DeepSig已经完成了首轮外部融资。
总额超过500亿人民币。
约合74亿美元
而DeepSig的估值也超过了500亿美元。
在这次融资过程当中。
创始人梁文峰个人出资200亿元。
是最大的出资方
腾讯投入100亿元。
宁德时代投资了50亿元。
京东网易还有IDG资本。
个投了30亿
这轮融资的交易结构也比较特殊。
除了国家人工智能产业投资基金。
直接投资了DeepSig。
其他的投资者的资金。
统一注入到了一个由梁文峰管理的企业。
并不想有投票权
股份还附带5年锁定期。
不能够转让
报道还提到
梁文峰要求核查基金背后合伙人的身份。
防止股份落入身份不明的投资者手中。
而5年的锁定期
目的也是要筛掉那些追求。
快速退出的投资者。
泡泡马特手游停止运营。
最近泡泡马特旗下的自言手游。
梦想家园
宣布将在今年8月12号。
正式终止运营
根据界面新闻的报道梦想家园。
早在2019年就拿到了版号。
但直到2024年的6月。
才正式上线
筹备了5年的时间。
这款模拟经营加派对玩法的手游。
集合了Molly、La Boubou等等。
泡泡马特旗下热门IP角色。
上线初期
一度登上了IOS中国区。
下载榜的第一名
泡泡马特CEO王宁当时表示。
梦想家园并不追求短期收益。
而是希望和主题乐园。
等等线下业务结合。
延长IP的生命周期。
不过今年5月王宁表示。
泡泡马特的电影和游戏业务都做得不够成功。
财务数据显示
负责运营这款游戏的公司。
两年累计亏损接近1.2亿元。
福克斯收购流媒体平台Rocco。
6月15日
美国媒体公司福克斯宣布。
以大约220亿美元的价格。
收购了Rocco。
这是福克斯迄今为止最大的一笔交易。
Rocco是一家流媒体公司。
它最知名的产品
是可以插在电视上的电视棒。
用户通过它在电视上。
可以观看耐飞 HBO Max 等流媒体的内容。
Rocco在全球拥有超过1亿个家庭用户。
也是美国最大的智能电视平台。
福克斯在2019年以700多亿美元的价格。
将娱乐资产出售给迪士尼之后。
一直围绕新闻和体育两大业务进行运营。
金融时报的分析认为福克斯背后的莫多克家族。
很少进行大额的收购。
这笔收购可能是源自于。
福克斯在流媒体时代面临的挑战。
过去15年美国有限和微信电视的用户数。
缩减了超过一半
目前只剩下大约5000万。
越来越多的人在电视上订阅流媒体套餐。
尤其是价格更低
带有广告的套餐
2020年他们以大约4亿美元收购了免费流媒体2B。
去年又推出了订阅制的Fox1。
不过这笔交易可能也会限制福克斯。
未来竞标体育转播权的能力。
以上就是我们编辑部为你输了的几条商业科技动态。
下面和我一同走进到今天的。
清洁毒时间
欢迎来到今天的清洁毒。
2003年东鹏公司的主推产品。
还是菊花茶等广东地区常见的纸盒饮料。
但是由于经营不善。
这家国营饮料厂当时正冰零破产。
他们的一位员工叫做林木勤。
他看到了机会
决定出资买下公司的品牌和生产设备。
多家媒体的公开报道显示。
林木勤曾经在国内一家红牛的代工厂工作过。
他很熟悉红牛的产品和运作逻辑。
也很早就在东鹏开发了类似的能量饮料。
东鹏特饮
从黄底蓝字的贯装包装。
到牛黄酸 咖啡因等成分。
甚至口味都和红牛比较相似。
只是一直没能找到销售突破口。
也就没有受到太多的重视。
不过林木勤逐渐发现。
在当时的中国市场。
货车司机等的蓝领。
才是能量饮料的刚需人群。
他们继续要提神行脑。
还得要补充体力
由此东鹏特饮
江木光也瞄准了工人云极的东管。
希望在东管打造样板市场。
2009年他们推出了塑料瓶装的东鹏特饮。
500毫升的东鹏特饮售价是5块。
而250毫升的红牛却卖到6块。
财经杂志指出
红牛的伊拉惯包装。
要比东鹏的塑料瓶包装贵了5毛以上。
节省包装成本
是东鹏能够实现高性价比的主要原因。
借助红牛培育的
中国能量饮料市场基础。
以及红牛评替的策略。
东鹏迅速打开了局面。
顾客以长途货车司机建筑工人。
等等重体力劳动人群为主。
2012年东鹏特饮的销售额破译。
公司也开始向全国市场拓展。
之后的一年时间
红牛更换了他们
困了累了喝红牛的广告语。
而东鹏则是直接把这句广告语换了个顺序。
打出累了困了和东鹏特饮。
还签约谢廷峰作为他们的品牌代言人。
东鹏很快成为了
国内能量饮料市场的第二名。
也开始进入了电解制水。
紧引咖啡等等其他的赛道。
2021年他们的第一款。
紧引咖啡正式上市。
到今年5月
东鹏已经在中国线下零售市场。
超越了星巴克
暂时成为了紧引咖啡赛道的第二名。
东鹏最新的财报也显示。
今年前三个月
能量饮料的收入占比是75%。
而去年同一时间
还要占到80%
紧引咖啡所在的其他饮料。
也是增速最快的业务。
他们的收入占比已经来到了14%。
那么东鹏的平装咖啡。
又做对了什么？
他们又沿用了
哪些能量饮料的打法呢？
打法之一
延续性价比策略
目前东鹏一共推出了。
经典拿铁和生液拿铁。
这两个口味的平装咖啡产品。
覆盖330毫升和500毫升的规格。
见面新闻在深圳的一家超市发现。
东鹏330毫升咖啡产品的售价是4.5。
而规格更小的确潮。
Costa在基本要卖到5块。
281毫升的星巴克新兵乐级饮咖啡。
更是售价13块左右。
晚点的报道也提到。
和确潮星巴克等的对手相比。
东鹏走的显然是大容量低价的路线。
另外快销市场监测机构马上引指出。
长期以来中国级饮咖啡市场是。
得拿铁者得天下
拿铁霸占了整个内幕。
7成以上的销售额权重。
它还有着自己独特的定价逻辑。
具体来看在限制咖啡当中。
咖啡浓缩加奶而来的拿铁。
复杂程度要高于浓缩加水做成的美式咖啡。
所以定价通常也会更高。
但是在挤引咖啡里。
每100毫升拿铁的平均价格是2块。
要低于同规格
美式2块无以上的均价。
这个不同主要是因为那些。
不爱甜不爱奶的用户。
会更倾向于选择平装美式。
美式是更加纯粹的咖啡需求。
平装拿铁的部分顾客。
则是出于对饮料需求进行购买的。
它的价格也要更加亲民。
而东鹏推出的产品。
也同样更加贴近咖啡饮料的定位。
是作为好喝的饮料和其他品类来竞争的。
所以相比之下
确潮核心巴克所代表的传统咖啡巨头。
他们平装咖啡的销售额。
基本都在300毫升的产品以内。
容量比较小
更加强调的是
挤引咖啡最初的功能性提神的定位。
大法之二
附用下唇市场渠道。
中泰证券的报告指出。
像瑞信库迪这样的限制咖啡品牌。
通过密集的门店点位和低价9.9策略。
推动了中国咖啡消费从过去的社交属性。
向日常属性转型
也培养了一大批年轻消费者的咖啡依赖度。
同时喝咖啡概念
在下唇市场的渗透率还在持续的提升。
而这也能够让东鹏集团发挥长期以来。
在渠道上的优势
界面新闻的报道显示。
东鹏没有把咖啡铺获的主要战场。
放在高端便利店
而是更多的依托于他们原有的渠道网络。
进入加油站、高校、夫妻老婆店。
还有下唇市场的小店等等中端。
去年东鹏已经拥有了3400多家竞销商。
渠道覆盖了全国的所有地际市。
另外东鹏还把他们意愿乐想的营销玩法。
继续复制到了紧引咖啡品类上。
消费者购买产品之后如果开盖中奖。
就可以通过扫码和销。
以一块钱的价格再购买一瓶。
华创证券指出
新品牌做品妆饮料。
通常要给渠道各个环节。
流出充足的利润
那些给消费者核销换购的门店。
也能够从东鹏集团那里获得相应的奖励。
2023年底
东鹏咖啡产品的渠道利润。
在所有的竞品当中排名第一。
如果只是比对出厂价和中端零售价的话。
那他们渠道毛利率大约是33%。
但是加上意愿乐想活动。
渠道的利润就可以接近45%。
不过这家公司依赖的渠道建设和促销活动。
显然也需要投入大量的成本。
见面新闻认为
当消费者不再因为意愿乐想。
或者是低价长先而购买的时候。
东鹏的咖啡饮品
能否用口味和品牌认知留住用户。
还要打一个问号
毕竟集影咖啡已经是一个相对成绩的品类。
还在被限制咖啡持续的分流。
所以它也并不是一个高速增长的风口。
欧瑞国际的数据显示。
去年中国咖啡市场接近1500亿元。
限制咖啡占比大约是85%。
保持双位数的增长。
但是集影咖啡赛道却早就已经接近停滞。
中国银河证券研究院还指出。
同样是东鹏推出的新品类。
电解制水的销售额和铺货率。
都要比集影咖啡增长更快。
同时星巴克等等老玩家。
还在围绕咖啡消费者更兴奋的需求。
研发更多的创新产品。
比如他们刚刚推出了带装的集影咖啡。
农夫山泉 瑞幸等等。
同样具备品牌和渠道资产的玩家。
也在入局集影咖啡领域。
如何让消费者长期复购。
或许是各个品牌共同面临的难题。
那你平时会购买瓶装或者是冠装的集影咖啡吗？
一般情况下又会是在什么样的场景下购买呢？
欢迎在我们的评论区和我们一块来聊聊。
好啦 这就是今天的生动早咖啡。
那我们明天一早再见啦 拜拜。
如果有发现必追究责任。